[Music]
we're gonna be talking about something
that might make you feel a little
squeamish everybody needs to be at the
babies filming us today yeah we just
want to warn you and warn everyone else
but it might get a little wrong I like
my lady bits after I gave birth here's
something you need to know about sex
after babies whether or not your doctor
communicates this to you six weeks is a
standards that you should be waiting six
weeks but I'll tell you even beyond six
weeks man I know when I got the
all-clear from the doctor I did not come
home and and jump in the sack be like
six more months six more months sorry
honey it's like a winter okay how long
did you wait have sex after your first
baby I waited a while I waited about
three months my OBGYN terrified [ __ ] out
of me about having sex one of our visits
she was like so Oh chief you need to
know that you're gonna need a lot of
loot then let me think you've had enough
Luke put another bottle on it was like
wait what's that
what was your Lube bill our first night
use some like novelty Lube that we got
no I got
that party it was like his-and-hers
warming but oh not the brand-name stuff
guys brand was like Brand X my plan that
you guys a little bit us on fire like it
literally burned [ __ ] horrendous what
does sex after baby feel like virginity
it's not virginity and that like your
husband is also bad at sex or is it just
the time okay I always thought that
after you had a baby your vagina was
supposed to be this like giant big hey
yes vagina flapping in the wind
[Music]
I just felt like can everybody stop
needing something from my body from yeah
cuz it's like you you obviously you've
married this person or you've chosen to
have a child with them and you maybe
live together and you want them to feel
happy and satisfied you want to please
your partner but it's not pleasing for
you and we're in that line everybody's
frustrated like you're frustrated cuz it
hurts so you don't want to go there and
like they come near you and you're just
like yeah and you don't want to be like
that you want to be loving to them I
think it's super important that you know
a lot of women have babies and feel
pressure to get back in the sack with
their partner it really is about you
feeling confident and comfortable in
your body you've got to be ready and it
can hurt so don't rush into it you can
also hurt yourself if you have sex too
early because it's a big can open wound
in your uterus where your placenta used
to be so how long before all the sex
stuff was back to normal
it wasn't back to normal until I stopped
breastfeeding yeah how long was that
breastfed for a year I'm gonna say a
year it really wasn't
it really wasn't back to Nora
but it's better now Christine yeah what
do you think you ready to have a baby no
my subscription I cannot accept this
award
I'm watching my hair that day good
enough yes good
I don't scare someone out of having
children every single day it's like I
haven't lived all right okay thanks for
watchin your mom go have sex but use a
lot of Lube and if you're not a mom
don't have sex because you'll become one
[Music]